We are here with Yuzuru.
Yuzuru, how are you?
How did you feel today on the ice?
Tired.
It's hard,...
...hard and feeling stronger and then harder again and then exhausted.
At the end, exhausted.
What do you bring home from this experience?
Something to work on specifically?
Especially for the quad lutz.
I feel really good with music...
...with the quad loop too.
It really makes me happy to practice and bring it back.
I think it is really an important step for me.
And you have an amazing connection with your fans and with all the fans of figure skating.
Did you feel it today?
Did you feel it today on the ice, you tried to have it?
Yeah, because when I was doing the quad loop, I'm feeling more...
If I'm not doing quad lutz for the second jump,...
...I feel really nervous for the quad loop.
It was the most difficult jump.
So, I think my fans, audience, have the nervous feeling for the quad loop,...
...but today, I'm feeling a little lighter because I have more decision for the lutz.
So I'm feeling a little lighter, "Okay, I can feel lighter for the loop."
And when I'm doing a pattern for the lutz, my feet are much heavier.
Everyone is nervous too.
So, it's like a special moment for me.
I feel a connection to the audience, you know.
That's why I'm skating.
Of course, of course.
Well, thank you very much for your performances, for what you do in every competition for us.
And good luck for the rest of the season.
Thank you.